and thank you for all your help. If a person's cancer is progressing while using the true rife,
would you recommend getting the atelier robin machine or getting new programming for the true rife?
Scott has been using the true rife for a little over two years.
So, you know, we've most people that are listening to me right now are using the true rife.
We've used the true rife machine since, I don't know, 2008 or something. I can't remember.
I've just talked to somebody on the phone late last week that they needed a new computer for their
rife. But I said, you know, you're not even in our new software that we use for our patients.
Remind me again, when you started with me, she said, I think it was 10, 12 years ago.
So, she's been doing well for a long time and her, but her bulb went out and her computer went out.
So, we've been using the true rife for a very long time because I've always promised to my patients
that I would always use the best machine that I think that's out there in the market. Before true
rife came around, when I first started with this, we started with a beam ray and a light beam generator.
Now, those would be extremely antiquated machines at this point in the discussion.
And my old beam ray machine, honestly, what I had still had my storage unit, oh gosh,
this is like, years ago, I ended up throwing it away because I couldn't consciously sell it to
anybody in good conscience. It's like, there's just no way, there's just no way. I can, I'm never
going to use this again, I just tossed it. So, true rife was the best in the market for a very long time.
Now, I'm convinced the Atelier Robin is a better machine. For multiple reasons,
and I share some of those reasons on the frequency course.
It should a person get a switch to the Atelier Robin if they have a true rife.
Well, if they're doing well and they're staying stable, I would say absolutely not. No, I don't think
it's that big of a difference if you're doing well. If I'm not doing well and my cancer is
progressed and it just took off again, should that be something I consider?
If you can financially do it, maybe it would be something I would consider.
Because I do think that it adds enough extra benefit. So, in a perfect world, if there was no cost
to them and to upgrade them, I'd say everybody should upgrade it. But there's a cost. It still costs
me money to do that. I can't just give machines away for free. It's just not possible. But the benefit
of the Atelier Robin is it allows us to do harmonic frequencies. So, that's one benefit. So, a
harmonic frequency is doing two frequencies at the same time. And one, so a harmonic frequency is a
mathematical equation of doubling that frequency, tripling that frequency, quadrupling,
that frequency, et cetera. And there's evidence that running harmonics with the frequency can add
benefits. The big information out there is running what's called the 11th harmonic, which is 11 times
that frequency. Let's have running frequency of 2000. So, the 11th harmonic is going to be 22,000. So,
you're running 22,000 hertz. I'm talking about hertz. So, you're running that frequency. Let's say
you're already 2000 and 22,000 at the same time overlapping each other. It could have a big benefit
when you're trying to kill pathogens, living things, living cells. So, the benefit that we have with
the Atelier Robin is that I can write your program running the 11th harmonic so that we are
covering more bases to be able to have a better chance to kill the cancer. So, that's a super
exciting feature that we have with the Atelier Robin. The other feature that I think is makes the
Atelier Robin more superior is the true rifle. It goes up to about 10 to 12,000 hertz. That's the
most you could go up with the bulb. Any other higher frequencies you have to do with the footpath.
And it can only go up to about 30,000 with the footpath. With the Atelier Robin, we could go up to 30,000
hertz with the bulb, which were then catching all of life's original frequencies with the bulb.
And then with the footpath, if you wanted to add the footpath, you could go up to 100,000 actually a
million hertz with the footpath. Now, I don't even, with the Atelier Robin, I don't even recommend
the footpath. So, though we have a number of people with the Atelier Robin that wanted to have
the footpath also, which is fine. But I don't think you need the footpath with the Atelier Robin.
So, there's several other benefits with the Atelier Robin that we could get into as well. So,
but for me to say, oh, that's it, you just need this new machine. That's what's going to turn your
cancer around. That would, that would be a lie. I don't, I can't say that. That would be a promise
that I could not make. So, I couldn't say that. If it was me and money wasn't an issue, would I buy
it until if my cancer was going the wrong way, would I run it, would I get an Atelier Robin?
Yes. Again, everybody here knows if you were, if you were in this group what my cancer was bad,
I was still doing zoom calls and I was sharing with you my protocol and exactly what I was doing.
I was running, I just told you before, I was running the true rife all night long.
I got to work and I'd run I ran the GB 4000. That's a different machine that allows you to go
higher frequencies because it's using a totally different technology. But you it has lots of
negatives. I didn't ever, I never recommended buying a GB 4000 for people because it has a whole
bunch of other negatives. But I know how to run the GB 4000. So, I run the GB 4000 during the day
and run the true rife at night because I had the true rife at home. You can't,
running the GB 4000, you can't run it all night long. That was one of the big negatives of the GB 4000.
Now, I would never recommend the GB 4000 now that we have the Atelier Robin because it's like the
GB 4000 and the true rife had a baby and the baby is much brighter. But yeah, in a perfect world,
yeah, I would try Atelier Robin. That's what I would do. But you know, it everybody's different.
So, if you're sitting here, listening to this and going, oh, I have a true rife,
should I trade my true rife in? If you're doing well, I'd say no, no, you should it.
Well, I don't know if I'm doing well, you know, I've just had it for six months or so and I've
just been trying. Well, just keep going here and we'll keep testing, you know, so I don't know,
I don't have any data on people and I've had a true rife and then have changed to the Atelier Robin
and their cancer turned around because we have never tried that yet on anybody, okay, because
the Atelier Robin machine is only four months old. So, it's, I don't know if it would make that
big of a difference quite honestly. I can't say yes or no. If it was me and I was in your situation,
I would do it. But it also depends on a person's financial situation. So,
you know, that's what I've said in past Zoom calls. A lot of people are, a lot of people get two
rife machines. They have one up in their bedroom and then they have one down to their living room.
Well, if you're thinking about getting a second rife machine, buy an Atelier Robin.
So, if I have people call me on a case review and they're like talking to me and they're like,
I want to get a rife machine, which one should I get? I'll say in Atelier Robin. If they say,
which I've had this happen, no, no, people have said no, I want to get a true rife. My sister had
a true rife and it was, okay, let's get you a true rife. I love true rife, okay? But I just love
Atelier Robin more. So, that's my recommendation. I have never compared the two. We don't, we don't,
I mean, as far as, hey, study or anything like that, I would never jeopardize somebody's health to do so.
So, I can't tell you, you know, we heard, honestly, you see all our testimonials. We have hundreds
and hundreds of people that have had phenomenal success with their therapies, but I've also
sat in the past two that I, you know, to be honest, I don't know if it was a rife that helped that
person heal cancer or was it, you know, their supplements or was it their loving spouse or was it
the combination of chemo or was it their attitude or was it their belief? I don't know. And we've
seen miracles with animals with true rife. So, there was no placebo effect whatsoever. The dog got
better. How do you explain that one? They didn't do anything else, but do the rife. And it was the
true rife. So, the true rife is a phenomenal tool. So, I don't want to make anybody think that they
need to run out and make changes. But if you are thinking about getting a second one or if your
cancer is progressing a year, willing to try something else then by all means that would be the
choice. Question from the chat. If a current member would want to purchase the Chilean Robin at some
point, what would be that cost? You'll just have to call Angie and talk to her about that we would
give you a slight discount because of the programming. But the programming for, it wouldn't be a big
discount because the programming for the Chilean Robin is different. So I've added the 11th harmonic
to the program and rewriting your whole program. So, your program would be different than your true
rife program.